explore what you want to do before
committing is really like the the key
thing
if you're going to be great at something
you've got to make the effort to be
great at something
life has dreamed a dream for you and
your
your goal your number one job is to
figure out what that dream is
wanna be happy live a life not just a
business
[Music]
living i believe in life and i believe
in life
every day
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you have
michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the five traits
that will make you
extremely successful enjoy
okay let's kick it off with trait number
one be flexible with mark zuckerberg
for me so much of the lesson that that i
i feel like i've learned is
i feel like it's really hard to decide
to start a company right
you know facebook i didn't start it to
start a company i started it because
i really wanted this thing personally
and i believed that it should exist
globally
although i wasn't quite sure that we
would be able to play a role in doing
that
and um it was mostly just through kind
of like wanting to
build it and having it be this hobby and
getting people around me excited that it
eventually kind of evolved into and got
the momentum to become a company but
i never really understood the psychology
of deciding that you want to start a
company before you understand what you
want to do
and i know that that's not that that's
different from your philosophy on this
no no believe me i wish we would get
more people who
who where the company started them
rather than vice versa one of the issues
is just
once you this gets back to the question
of why did we why did we first open it
at colleges that had competitors i have
this big
fear i think of getting locked into
doing things that aren't actually the
most impactful things and to me this is
like
the trait that entrepreneurs have is
they just have this like
laser-like ability to go find where they
can have the most impact and
you know when you take on a new project
especially if you hire people or start a
company you're doing that project and i
mean there are ways there are obviously
different ways that it can exit and all
that but
i think having the flexibility to
explore a lot of different things which
you can do when you're in college which
is one of the amazing things about being
in college is you can work on all these
hobbies
um and encode a lot of stuff and try a
lot of different things
it's this amazing flexibility that i
think most people take for granted and
once you decide
okay i'm going to start a company and
i'm going to do it with someone else you
immediately now need to convince someone
else if you want to change your mind on
something and i think people really
undervalue the option value and
flexibility
so stay in college um i think
explore what you want to do before
committing is really like the key thing
and keep yourself flexible and
no i think that that's yeah i agree yeah
but but i think
you can definitely do that within the
framework of a company but i think you
have to be wary about
starting a company um too rigidly
because you're gonna change what you do
i mean people talk about
pivots all the time as if it's like it
didn't didn't your thing didn't work so
you pivoted
facebook pivoted many times i mean just
that you know we kind of we were college
and then we were not college and then we
were just a website and then we were a
platform right and
um you're gonna change what you do right
and um
you have there's another word for the
kind of pivots you're talking about
expansions
oh right that's not what people usually
mean by pivoting
well you know flexibility
trait number two always keep learning
with mark cuban if you're going to be
great at something you've got to make
the effort to be great at something
whether it's sports whether it's physics
math
science business whatever it may be
you know it's not just a natural skill
you've got you've got to
to learn and particularly if you're in
the technology industry because it
changes every day
you know when i got started in in
you know after i got i i got it i was a
bartender when i first came to dallas
got
into the pc industry got fired started
my own company
but there i learned early on that there
was always something new
and most people didn't put in the time
to learn it
it's like now with artificial
intelligence lots of people talk about
artificial intelligence
lots of people talk about machine
learning and neural networks not a lot
of people are putting in the time to
take classes or do the tutorials or
to to learn how to apply it to business
and that's what it takes and
and you know that's just something i've
always enjoyed so that i've been
fortunate at that now wait a minute are
you doing that with ai right absolutely
what are you doing oh i mean i've been
on amazon doing the machine learning
tutorials
right now i'm going through um i've
taken python
online classes really yeah absolutely um
if you go in my bathroom there's a
machine learning for dummies book
um i just started uh javascript neural
networks
um there's a little tutorial where
they've got most of the library brain.js
and
all the libraries and it's not if you
have a background in programming it's
not hard
but i'm not trying to be great at that
but i want to understand it so i
understand
all the you know so i the nuanced
elements of it and how it works so that
i have an advantage trait number three
align yourself with your dream with
oprah winfrey
life has dreamed a dream for you and
your
your goal your number one job is to
figure out what that dream is
and align yourself with the dream
because the dream cannot come to you
unless you're willing to meet
it energetically in the same place
so if your energy is off which i say to
my girls all the time
they could teach this class right now on
being in flow
if you are not in flow with
god's dream for you with life's dream
for you
if you are out of order if you are out
of sync
it cannot come to you it will not
come because the whole purpose of your
life
is to line yourself up with the purpose
and so if you are operating in fear
if you are operating in uh jealousy
jealousy will kill you when you are
synced up with life
life just gives to you it opens doors
it creates experiences it allows you to
meet people
things show up you never thought were
going to show up and
you are doing what
is the purpose of your soul being here
also if you want to have unstoppable
confidence and learn from billionaires
check out my 254 series they're free
the links are joined on the description
below i've always been passionate
some people thought you know it's more
ocd than anything else
you know microsoft did that and i like i
have a huge amount of respect for for
him for doing that he pushed them and
it was an incredibly inspiring company
um during the time that he was doing
that i think that they're
they still are doing a lot of things but
i think that they've lost some of the
focus
you must know inside in the deepest
part of your being that you matter
not just that you matter but also why
treat number four associate with better
people than you
with warren buffett the most important
thing
uh aside from the things i've talked
about already
is it's really who you associate with
you want to associate with people that
are better than you are i mean basically
you'll go in the direction of the people
that you associate with
and and you want to have the right
heroes uh
you want people if you want to emulate
somebody you better pick
very carefully who you want to emulate
and
and when obviously you can't pick your
parents
they're going to have an enormous
influence on you but you don't get a
choice on that but you get choices
as you go down the line and you who you
uh who you admire who you who who you
want to copy and the most important for
most people in terms of that decision is
their spouse
it's also important in terms of a
partner in business but the partner in
life is
is the most important one you want to
pick a spouse that's a little that's
better than you are
and trait number five the last one
before a very special bonus trait
is be a great teacher with jack ma
when your company is only a poor tractor
don't try to buy a boeing 747 engine in
it
because the it's not the point it's not
the bullying engine problem
it's your problem we're not ready don't
think
great people great people
always in your company those people
believe in you
those people following you you should
spend the time
training them working with them and
develop them with them together
invest in them and then the company grow
this is a lesson i learned
you mentioned hr problems as well you
have an enormous operation
i mean when it was so different from
when you were in your apartment 20 years
ago
yeah what was the hr what were the hr
problems which overwhelmed you
well a lot of people want to have a
quick success they tried to
head hunting people right i want to get
the guy i want that guy
um i want to win the competition if you
want to win the competition always in
your mind you're a professional killer
you're not the guy thinking about
developing a company
so i was a teacher i had no experience
of marketing i don't i don't know
anything about technology i don't know
anything about
uh accounting actually so i know as a
teacher
the best way is to find good students
find the people who are
better than you are find the people who
are smart you are
believing your students are smarter than
you are so past 20 years
i try my best to be a good teacher
i call myself ceo chief education
officer
i learn from a teacher a teacher
yeah thank you
i teach a good teacher always hope
that his students do better than him a
good teacher feel proud
my this student become a tv anchor might
this student become a banker that
student become a mayor no teacher wants
this guy bankrupt bad student in jail
you know nobody wants that
so if you want your students to better
you should give them more chance
you should trust them you should give
them opportunities
so from what i learned from my hr
i trust my people now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you going
to do
to take action on it this week when you
write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan
to take action on it this week let me
know put it down
in the comments below in your master
class you know you talk a lot about the
tools that you use to develop
big ideas one of them is you let your
mind wander for
you know an hour to a day in the car you
created a fake commute
and since a lot of people today have
more time than usual
to let their minds wander at home how
can they use this situation
to help develop their ideas
well i mean you mentioned the think time
think time to me is really important
and i don't what i'm talking about is
not going through your list of things to
do at work
or your chores in the home it's like
where does your mind wander because when
it just wanders with no agenda
and you're almost in this sort of
quasi-daydream
state that's where really magic happens
that's where sparks fly that's where
like you're being channeled
i feel like there's a connection that's
happening between you and the universe
and um i get flooded with ideas when i'm
in that state
you know since being at home for a
significant period of time
and with forced small children um my
creativity and my idea flow has
not been what i would love for it to be
but my creativity has sort of shifted
into
full-blown mom mode and i'm
coming up with creative things to do
with the children and
creative you know activities from
storytelling and i'm going to start the
story and i want you guys to finish the
story
to scavenger hunts in the backyard or on
a beach so
um my mind is kind of working in other
ways right now because it's really sort
of
been all hands on deck at home
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check the link right
here below me or if you want to know
what billionaires do
every day check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy
them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there